[Music]
hey you guys it's episode 56 of the
matinee show if you will notice remember
on one show I don't know what episode it
was I said we would like to have a
little Santa hat for the holiday season
I know it's not the holiday season but I
figured that it just could be his
Halloween costume as well our friend
Terris an us I wasn't expecting it and I
just got this tiny little package in the
mail just like I opened it my ass up
look at him but looks like you know in
cases a little bald gets cold you know
it's a Christmas time you know Merry
Christmas
yeah we have Christmas in prison of
course is the day that Jesus was born
he's got the little cross right there
yeah all right
so as usual we're going to be reviewing
three new things again we did I think we
did two on shudder this weekend one in
the theater so the first one we're going
to be talking about is creep show 2019
the series episode four yeah shudder
exclusive a shutter exclusive yeah once
again this series delivering I I liked
the first one a lot better than the
second one I have to say you would you
know each one's a little variety you got
you know variety you know yeah the first
one was was classic you know kind of
reminded me of like an old night gallery
episode it was a bit like that yeah yeah
it's about this guy you know splat guy
he's a farmer and his wife dies so he
decides to make a companion this is like
this looks like it's happening sometime
in the weather thirties when he did that
it's hard yeah I'm not sure how long ago
it was supposed to yeah it's kinda you
can't it's hard to tell what timeframe
this is hat because the modern time
frame that lays it is in yeah turned a
but then like when he goes back and
finds like yeah I don't want to spoil it
dude made a made a companion was kind of
like a damn scarecrow in clothes made
out of damn animal bones and it came to
life and it killed a little girl a Girl
Scout
yeah Girl Scout say he sounds pretty
brutal laugh today yeah
I took it apart or something or no he
put a he put like a cane like three yes
very sorry it has like a fabric heart
that his wife had made before you died
yeah and that seemed to be the thing
that was animating it yeah yeah really
just you know you know that's all you
find all that out kind of like in a
flashbacks about this kid being bullied
this bully's beaten his has beaten him
up so he was like a brother his brother
yeah okay
so he runs off he runs off out into the
woods and and runs upon this old
abandoned farmhouse and he goes down in
there and damn monsters chasing him this
this scares like a scarecrow looking
type thing with animal bones in it even
goes downstairs and finds the old guy
you know but this head blowed off it's
rotten old body down in there it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool yeah this
one the first one if we didn't mention
it this is called the companion the
Kabam
and it was actually was directed by
David Bruckner who did you know a couple
of other segments on this series also
screenplay was done by Matt veni but it
was actually based on a story by Joel
and Dale and as well as Casey Lansdale
and Keith land sales they kind of
collaborated on this one I can't
remember the name of the short story
collection that this was in bumper crap
I think it was called um so that's where
this came from
and it really gave me like one I have to
say the scarecrow monster effects are
great this is like a really cool looking
monster like I especially like like all
his fingers like I they come out and
it's like old vines and sticks and stuff
like that yeah that was like really
really cool yeah it's like something
kind of like out of [ __ ] folklore and
I like and I like the UH the the farmer
was played by an old black guy but you
like totally buy into it that this this
guy's character you know no man he's
just like this super depressed old black
dude that could live in out understand a
farm you know running this you know wife
died and it's just it's just a [ __ ]
sky reminds me of an old creepy night
gallery story yeah very much like the
night gallery that kid they care
the farmer in particular I think is very
kind of similar to you know it had like
the very much the same tone is like the
first movie from 1982 I also have to say
too that when the kid was like running
from the bully and finds the the blown
the the farmer with the blown off head
but the shotgun is everything in the
basement of the farmer I thought they
were gonna do I thought it was gonna be
Jordy Verrill from the first movie yeah
didn't you think that - yeah I kind of
thought that it was something to do
maybe I mean maybe they were just like
Oh moshing that but I was sitting there
going hey is that armored barrel look
like this is some like new offshoot of
that story of which I thought that yeah
well I suspected it at the time but then
when it goes to the flashback tells you
yeah totally different yeah and and and
the Stephen King majority is that his
name short he's already barely yeah he
was upstairs when he blew his head off
that's right and there was moss and
fungus everywhere yeah you know this one
just had a bunch of vines yeah so it was
it was a different story it was it was
good though but I do feel like it might
have been a logic not a little bit yeah
but it kind of reminded me of some of
those creepy Night Gallery stories about
the kid who has the monster and buries
it up in rocks member and it comes out
later yeah you're talking about and then
the one where the the boys are playing
around in that old guy's farm and he's
telling them to dig go go go to that old
tree and go east and go ten paces and
dig dig and you'll find a big surprise
remember that and they dig down there
and find that damn box and the old man
comes that was surprised that was that
old dude I do remember that was a
surprise give that kid a damn heart
attack that's right whoa this reminded
me to a little bit [ __ ] me when I was a
kid this had a very similar vibe to the
recent scary stories to tell in the dark
particularly the one you know the kind
of the the Scarecrow little vignette
about that like about the bully getting
killed and stuff but like I said I'm not
sure how old the Joel and stale stories
that this is based on but it just gave
me kind of like a similar vibe to that
also a little bit like goosebumps but
scarier than that and also like I said a
Girl Scout gets killed by the sheer crow
like in a pretty horrible way pretty
damn heavy stories so
yeah like yeah I really I really ended
up liking this one like I said it
joe-joe lancedale you can't get that
creepy as that creeps no black dude as
the farmer he wasn't creepy just
depressing
kind of sad all dude you know I mean
it's I just thought it was funny it was
weird story cool thing about his
character was that I mean on its face it
seems like a ridiculous thing to do like
my wife is diet and I'm lonely and I
live out here this isolated farm I'm
gonna make the creepiest looking
scarecrow imaginable it's like just put
bones in it I mean yeah it's gonna be my
friend and then I think it comes to life
and you're like it was my bad why that
was so [ __ ] creepy dude but he just
like lead right into it and you bought
it you know yeah yeah yeah but yeah so I
really really liked this segment of it
called the companion now the second one
was called Lydia lanes better half and
this was actually an original story
which I believe was written by Greg
Nicotero who also directed actually no I
think maybe John Harrison wrote it and
then Greg Nicotero had come up with the
story but you know what I mean so this
one had to do with a woman who was like
she's like a Lydia the titular Lydia
Lane she is like a high powered CEO and
I guess she's got like she's up in this
like penthouse apartment or whatever and
she's got two candidates for I think
it's a promotion I don't remember if
it's CEO or CFO were one of those things
like in her company and she picks the
man the woman there is also happens to
be her girlfriend whose name is Celia
Celia is understandably miffed by this
development they have a large argument
Lydia subsequently well she doesn't kill
Celia it's an accident but then stupidly
she decides that well I can't find you
know no one can find this body in my
apartment even though it was clearly an
accident like her getting killed so she
tries to get rid of the body by taking
it down the hall and putting it in the
elevator and I don't know where she's
gonna take it then maybe should've put
in the dumpster on or off and then it so
happens that she gets stuck in the
elevator because there is an earthquake
so this one I mean it's a very simple
setup like I said it reminded me a lot
of a storyline that would have been on
the original Creepshow but I wasn't
super crazy about this one um I think it
was because maybe because the character
of Celia who was dead and she kept like
coming back to and creepy [ __ ] and you
weren't really sure if she was really
doing the creepy [ __ ] or if this was
like a telltale heart situation we're
just like Lydia's guilt was like making
her see all these things you know I
don't really know how that was playing
out but I felt like Lydia didn't really
deserve what she got because I feel like
a lot of the [ __ ] in the creep show I
mean the whole creep show thing like all
the stories better are usually like
revenge stories and it's usually like
bad people like having bad things happen
to them but Lydia you know it's like
yeah she was arguing with Celia she
didn't give her the promotion because
she you know maybe she thought the other
dude was better or she wanted to spend
more time with the girlfriend or
whatever but it's like she didn't really
like deserve what happened to her you
know what I mean so I feel like Celia
the one that got killed was like the bad
guy and she kind of ended up winning you
know I mean well it's just one of the
stories they're gonna tell us in this
series you know I mean they're every
story's different they're they're all
they're all good yeah but some are
better than others as well yeah which is
what you're gonna get with an anthology
shadows way it is um I liked this one
better than a couple of the other ones
but I do think this was one of the
weaker ones just because you kind of
knew how it was gonna play out it had
like some cool like gore effects it had
like some cool like suspense and stuff
like that but I don't know something
about it didn't really like grab me as
much as some of the other ones but that
said I really did like the companion and
like I said that's you know I probably
liked Lydia lanes better half a little
bit better than the All Hallows Eve one
just because it was gory ER and had more
of that you know it was like confined
space and it was you know kind of kind
of good in that way but still the moral
of the story is is that shudders worth
getting for damn 5 6 bucks a month you
know or what was it like $50 a year 6
which even knocks it down even even less
like four dollars and seven cents a
month yeah in the
you you get you get Creepshow included
which is a great series and a lot of old
classic horror movies oh my gosh there's
a bunch of other singers on the new ones
on there yeah I mean it's
I'm liking shudder more than I like
Netflix actually from my taste we're
just keeping Netflix because it's got
MST on there and a couple other little
series but for the money this is a good
stutters a good service well I have been
reading I read an article that came out
a couple days ago that said that creep
show was like breaking all shudders
streaming records like it was like the
highest you know streamed thing on the
service that looks like yeah I'm sure
that was a good investment to buy that
series yeah track people to it that's a
yeah I bought YouTube just so I can
watch Cobra Kai yeah I love coke I've I
hit two I'm still I'm just gonna keep
this yeah use a good enough series like
that will turn people on to your yes
service it's like especially if it's not
horribly expensive it's just like you
know five six boxes wait a month that's
like you know that's like throw away
money so I buy on a drink I spend it on
a drink yeah that's what I mean it's
like you spend more than that on a
[ __ ] cocktail for yeah it's like I've
spent more than twice the cocktail so
it's like not really that big a deal and
like you said you not only if you get
shudder you not only get like Creepshow
but you get like a whole bunch of other
cool [ __ ] as well yeah you're not gonna
see it on Netflix you're not gonna see
anywhere else yeah all blu-ray quality -
um I think there is only two more
episodes of creep show but since it's
been so successful I hate a new one I
would imagine that they will probably
continue with it because it looks like
they've gotten like a lot of new
subscriptions because of it and it's
kind of attracted a lot of new people so
we'll see how it goes like I said it's
you know it's an anthology series so
it's gonna be kind of a mixed bag some
of them are better than others but
that's kind of like the good thing about
it because ones that I think are the
best like other people didn't like so
much and vice versa even man or
something for everybody
Mandy started off as a shutter exclusive
didn't it yeah yeah like they didn't
make it but yeah they that was something
with the first David the first ones to
get it they had like exclusive rights to
it so they got it like very very shortly
after it
he's showing me that [ __ ] love it I
do too man did I get that on blu-ray no
you didn't I didn't get it I gotta get I
gotta get it on no we have to get that
yeah but yeah so Creepshow Episode four
will be doing Episode five next week we
haven't watched it yet usually we would
have watched it by nap we didn't get
rancid
you
all right so the second movie we took in
this week we actually saw a bunch of new
ones this week but this was the one that
we kind of both like the best we wanted
to talk about this one this one is
called the elds abouthe I guess I'm
pronouncing that right yeah this movie
was kind of surprising it's kind of like
a Southwest of the border Mexican
American adventure about possession yeah
it's almost kind of like hmm this is
another shutter exclusive on it it is
yeah it actually I think this came out
maybe in Mexico and South America last
year but it didn't premiere in North
America until June of 2009 at the sin
apocalypse fest yeah and then shudder
put it up just like a week or two ago or
maybe three weeks ago something like
that and yeah it's like it's um it's an
American Mexican co-production and it's
set on I guess it's set in like a border
town yeah like right on the border it's
almost kind of I want to say that it's
like the opposite of the omen you know
what I mean because you know how like
the omen is like it's the Antichrist and
like you have all these like evil people
like trying to protect the Antichrist
well this is like that except that
there's a kid that's the Messiah yeah
trap protect massage and then there's
like evil people like turn and then
there's like a pretty like a scary like
defrocked priest this that's trying to
protect the Messiah trying to find them
SIA and the evil people are trying to
protect him yeah and [ __ ] like that so
this was directed by a guy called Emilio
portes who I think the last thing he did
was actually a comedy and it might have
been like seven or eight years ago it's
been a while so you can't do one of
these kind of movies without having
without this story being told from the
Catholic perspective well yeah this is
work otherwise don't do this
as if Catholicism is real [ __ ] these
kind of stories fall apart so this is a
Catholic movie that's a Catholic horror
movie and it's cool it's got some
Mexican cops started to work with a dam
an American FBI guy who's all studies
into the paranormal yeah it's like he's
like a parrot it's like a paranormal
unit
yeah kind of like secret one like like
an x-files
yeah kind of like the guy from
frighteners the Jeffrey Combs characters
from the frighteners what was his name
oh yeah yeah who is kind of like a
paranormal FBI guy and the movies about
it's in English and Spanish about 50/50
so that games no matter where you market
it you just change the subtitles yeah
that's all you have to do so it's about
50% subtitled certain spots um yes but
it starts off with a bang
yeah the first 15 minutes okay yeah it's
good to miss it okay I'm watching this
when I saw it yeah okay I must say no I
have to say if you have a problem with
violence against children yeah yeah this
is not the movie for hit possessed
person goes nuts in the nursery and
kills up all the little kids and kills a
bunch of people with a damn was a knife
butcher knife right yeah and then one of
the kids that died was the cops it was
the cops son newborns saw it yeah he's
literally like just been just been born
then that's so that's how the movie
starts yeah and I was like alright my
attention so then so then the rest of
the story goes on it's got real good
visuals they kept they they kept CGI
down to a minimum they just bunch of
lighting effects there were some
practical effects but mostly what made
this made it good was just the
storytelling it's kind of an old school
an old school story in a way it's like
kind of like something it's kind of like
a movie that would have come out of the
80s of the 90s yeah content um you know
it's kind of like yes it's like a
possession movie it's a demon movie and
stuff like that but I think it kind of
it's elevated by this sort of like I
said the first 15 minutes are actually
quite shocking like you don't see a lot
of violence directed against this many
children in this particular way yeah so
I think it kind of has that aspect going
for it too that really gets you invest
in the characters and I have to say like
the main characters the main cop who's
newborn son gets killed at the beginning
his name's Emmanuel Ritter in the movie
he's played by Joaquin co-ceo who's been
at a bunch of other things I think he
was on narcos and a bunch of other stuff
but he plays this part so well because I
mean so after his son gets killed and
then there's like a five year gap and
then there's all these other like
terrorist attacks essentially that are
targeting children large groups of
children at once you know what I mean
yeah and so he has to look into why this
is happening and then he's kind of
butting heads with this you know
paranormal unit that comes down and one
guy in particular who's coming down from
the US because they know the whole demon
[ __ ] that's going on and yeah they know
about this rogue priest who's played by
Tobin Bell from saw and he's all like
the bald with a big beard and like
tattoos all over and he's like super
scary looking at [ __ ] like that but like
I said it's almost kind of like I have
to say that yeah that it's you can tell
that it's low-budget but the way that
they shot it is really nice the acting
is fantastic yeah you know there were a
couple little like CGI things like some
CGI blood that was okay and there was
one with like a Jesus yeah that was this
is the thing that threw me out of the
movie yeah all right it's a good movie I
liked it was I liked it a lot yeah
they spent money on some CGI and a scene
to wear a big crucifix of Jesus fell on
the ground and it got a demon started to
speak through animated yeah and tried to
animate it and it just looked little too
over-the-top I wouldn't have done any CG
at all I would have just had a
disembodied voice coming out of a damn
statue and done a camera angle from the
back of the damn crucifix showing the
guys looking at the crew you know
talking about yeah I think so you never
really saw the crucifix and the crucifix
didn't move but they would have heard a
voice coming coming out of it and maybe
the crucifix might have rattled or
something that would have been a lot
more effective well like I said were to
do well yeah and I would have bought
into that
like wow man and then they would have
been like did that happen did the voice
really come out of that you know instead
of having a damn jeez a jumpin Jesus
they had a dad jumpin Jesus on the
planet and there's like the paint's
crackin and fallen and it just it
doesn't look real
like it was kind of cool looking but it
was really obviously yeah yeah it was
very obvious CGI and the scene went on
for too long and just I just think it
was a waste of money it would have been
better to do with some disembodied
voices a camera angle maybe that maybe
just the like poltergeist activity yeah
that looked like Shannon shuddered and
that would have been a lot scarier well
in general sheep and I mean you know we
probably talked about this before in
general and horror movies not always
it's not like a across-the-board rule
but in general horror movies work better
when yeah less is more less is more like
when you don't show as much yeah like
you can't be so like we're never gonna
show anything and like it you know well
I don't know some movies have gotten
away with that that was all but that was
the only scene there I didn't agree with
the direction and what they did yeah
other than that and that I like the rest
of them um I did as well and I even
liked the way they shot like the opening
sequence with all the kind of attacks
against the kids and that's suddenly
right in it that's what I mean one it
was like it was dynamite beginning it's
like because it immediately got you like
into and you got really got like
emotionally invested into the cop
because that was like his baby and you
could literally see the like emotion on
his face and then actor yeah he is he's
been in a ton of other [ __ ] as well but
um you know and then [ __ ] happen with
his wife and all this other kind of
stuff so you could really see like his
pain and why he wanted to like sort this
out as much as like his partner was
being like man you shouldn't be on this
case because you're too closely related
to it you know and all this other kind
of stuff but he was just like dogged and
his determination to find out was going
on so he was really like the heart of
the movie and you know like you said
it's yeah it's like you know when it
gets toward the end it's kind of like
the omens sort of vibe but it's like a
little more action than the oven well
yeah it's a lot more action-packed than
that and I think it kind of had enough
of I mean there's so many possession
movies there's so many demon movies you
know I can see if people might get sick
of it with on the weekend you go the
movie goes South Amer
Nonya yeah that's it it's supposed to it
goes straight up South American Catholic
action demonic action movie yeah I was
loving it I understand a culture you're
not coming from Brazil I understand the
culture and it had a lot of elements of
an 80s or a 90s horror movie where it
was the the the writing was good you
know I mean it was it was it was a story
you know it was a story that you would
tell back then yeah and it's still
working the way the way that they showed
and then they did the classic move from
that era it left it open for a sequel
yeah they leave it open for a sequel and
everybody wants to see that even if you
didn't really like the movie you kind of
want I always liked the movie you still
kind of want to see it and where you
know you could make a sequel on that
yeah and you know they Telegraph it
which I liked it yeah is well it's like
it was yes its traditional I was
expecting it to be like pretty good but
it was actually like better than I
expected like especially like that
opening was just like fantastic yeah and
I liked the way that because you said
they had like that kind of Central
American South American flavor to it
yeah where the supernatural was like
pervading people's everyday lives yeah
which I thought was kind of like a cool
angle as well yeah so you know even if
you're like sick of demon movies or sick
of possession movies and like I said I
know there are a lot of one and there
are a lot of bad ones this was a good
one but this was actually a really good
one yes I thought it was fun you could
sit there drink and watch this movie
yeah so it's on shutter shutter
exclusive so if you don't have shutter
then you should get it because you need
to check out these first two things yeah
this was like a really really good movie
of nice surprise yeah
okay and the third movie we saw this
week we actually went to the theater and
see it this is what I've been looking
forward to for a long time this is the
lighthouse this is a weird-ass movie I
liked it I liked it
ah yeah the thing is though is that for
the general audience this is not a good
movie
well no it's this is definitely and
Robert Eggers does not make stuff first
general after this movie was over I
heard that people have a [ __ ] weird
what was that you know it it's it's kind
of like an old movie from the early 20s
or the teens it says shot at a real
tight aspect ratio like on an
old-fashioned camera it's about some
guys watching a lighthouse
you have to know certain things about
great mythology yeah understanding Toby
you have to know some stuff about
maritime culture and legends and legends
yes so if if your dumbass millennial and
you don't know this kind of [ __ ] you're
not gonna know what to make of this
[ __ ] movie things are gonna look like
MacGuffins when they're not really
MacGuffins they're symbolic for things
like Promethean fire and what a
Promethean death is they don't know much
about Poseidon and different
interpretations of gods that a God of
the land and a god of the sea and how a
man from the land might interpret God in
a different way than a man from the sea
a man from the Seas not gonna see he's
not gonna see Zeus he's gonna see
Poseidon as God and you know and then is
he gonna channel when he's and he gonna
channel Poseidon through him you know
and then there's a big [ __ ] story arc
about the water being bad so then they
have to drink booze and when that runs
out they start drinking the oil from the
damn lighthouse and are they going and
saying what the hell's happening you
know it's it's these it's a weird movie
it is very weird it's a weird it was
batshit crazy and I loved it I loved it
I thought it was amazing now I have to
say like I said if okay now this is the
second movie by Robert Eggers obviously
he got massive acclaim for the much
beloved horror film the witch this one
okay it's not super similar sanaya one
it's similar in the sense that it
concentrates on like New England
folklore like for the setting although
this one is actually set in the late
19th century whereas the which was set
in the 17th century
he also obviously again just like he did
in the which he took great pains to get
everything period exact you know just
like in the which where he used actual
dialogue from which trials and he got
all the you know clothes were period
specific and he got them all made
specifically he did the same thing with
this one he used like actual old ship
logs from the 1890s he used Herman
Melville's stories he used for all the
dialogue and things like that so he
could get it as period-accurate as he
could and like you said it's filmed in
black and white it's filmed in a very
tough like a 4:3 aspect ratio which
actually I I liked that because it made
it feel claustrophobic because that was
one of the themes of the movie was the
claustrophobia of these two guys in this
lighthouse on this island on this island
where there's nobody else around and
they're just like slowly driving each
other driving each other insane or are
they yeah you know I lived on a desert
island do you know when I was in the
Army op3 11 [ __ ] Anton in Egypt in
the MFO mission you can actually look it
look up op3 Elevens called the rock
there's actually videos of it on YouTube
but it's a bigger island than that and
there were about eight of us on it we'd
be out there at a month at a time and
that's how long these guys are gonna be
yeah it's been a month for weeks yeah
for weeks and we had bla better
amenities you know had electric power
and stuff and we didn't you know we
weren't getting pelted with them [ __ ]
waves and [ __ ] you know I mean and rain
all the time but I could kind of see it
from that point of view you know kind of
being in that situation personally I
think I'm probably harder to be there
with to people than it would be like
eight it would and variety of [ __ ]
people to talk to and they keep each
other in check well and we had contact
with the outside world we could see it
right you know so that make a big yeah
we were on the radio and you could just
look across the gulf of aqaba buttons
just
the Sharm el-sheikh you know they're
over there partying yeah you know when
the wind was right you could hear the
music coming from it yeah across across
the this one I think what and I really
think he did succeed in doing this this
movie is like it's almost kind of like a
like it was made back in the day yeah
when I must be made back in Indian
really are something maintenance look at
that it really looks like that
and it really kind of like sucks you
into that world and another thing that
he did really really well was like I
said I don't think audio gets kind of
enough accolades like particularly in
horror movies because I think it's a
really important aspect of horror movies
yeah but one thing he did like just from
the off was he just had this droning of
the lighthouse thing like going around
the waves crashing the birds squealing
and stuff and it just like puts you in
it it like puts you in the world along
with these guys and you could see
because the thing about it so there's
just two of them they don't know each
other prior to because I guess you know
the the lighthouse keepers or wiki's as
they call them you know they they are
there in 4 weeks shifts and then they're
supposed to have another team that comes
in relieves them so Willem Dafoe plays
Thomas wake I think his name is and he's
like the elder one he says he used to be
a sailor like back in the day but then
his leg got [ __ ] up either from
gangrene or cuz he broke it or whatever
and so he's been doing this lighthouse
thing for a long time and he has as his
second the guy played by Robert
Pattinson who who has never done this
before he used to be a guy he lived
worked worked in timber he was a lawyer
he was a logger and he so he's like been
doing this for the first time and
apparently he really wanted to you know
be a wiki and like work the light and
everything like that but Willem Dafoe
will not let him and he also just makes
him do like all this unpleasant [ __ ]
like around the around the lighthouse a
man is like he has to do all the
maintenance and he has to like empty
their chamber pots and stuff like that
because these two guys so there's so
there's this resentment simmering
between the younger guy and the older
guy so the younger guy they leave a lot
of it ambiguous as to how much is really
going on how how reliable either of the
narrator
are ya um you start to descend into
madness along but along with that
because you don't know what's the truth
and you don't know what really happened
or what's what's a damn an illusion and
what's what's symbolic you know what is
what's happening in somebody's mind
it's just weird scenes where there's one
weird scene where the wiki guy for a
second is portrayed as the lighthouse
with [ __ ] beam come out of his eyes
yeah hitting the other guy who's
touching another guy which is a long
story about how that happened so you
know is this the eye of God passing
judgment on somebody whose idea is this
you know it's just it's just it's a
weird movie it is very very weird it's
kind of like Eraserhead in a certain way
but more ya hear it it's yeah it's more
coherent than Eraserhead although but
it's a similar vibe because a lot of it
is surrealistic yeah like I said it
seems like grounded in reality at the
beginning but then there's like little
things three starts to fall apart as
they gets like you know someone's
supposed to come relieve them and they
don't come and it's like there's some
question about how long they've actually
been they're like you know he thinks
it's one time and the other guy thinks
no it's been this much longer and
there's stuff where you see something
happen and then one of the character
said no that's not how it happened
and inheritable I he'll say something
happened and then later says he'll say
oh I didn't say that I didn't say that
yes so it's it's almost kind of like
like you said I think it's very
successful not like like sucking you
into this world just because of how
claustrophobic it is and and with the
sound and everything like that but also
because you're just you're kind of in
the middle of a nightmare that you can't
get out of and you're not really sure
what's real or not because [ __ ]
rubber patterns
Paddington's character he keeps seeing
[ __ ] looked like you know
mermaids are like tentacles and he keeps
seeing stuff that you know can't be real
and then he looks back on it as if he
had sex with that mermaid
yeah and that it was a bad thing and
then it's you just it's just a movie you
gotta see you gotta be you either into
this kind of movie or you're not it's
definitely an experience yeah not a real
pleasant experience all the time it's
it's it's a you watch the movie and you
kind of go insane with these people if
you if you yeah and you can't have to
just let the movie do what it wants to
do just like okay but if you don't
there's a couple times where the
lighthouse keeper just goes on these big
tirades he gives a curse from Poseidon
there's a lot that's in there that it
has to do with the movie yeah and then
later on when the guy tries to take over
the lighthouse and he wants to look
inside the beam he makes a warning about
the fire with Prometheus and stuff and
if you're not really paying close
attention I have to go back and see
exactly what he said which explains how
it ends that and yeah it really spoils
like there's a lot of there's a lot of
solidly Mythology involved in this
particularly the story of Prometheus
that's really stole fire from the gods
and and this guy's stealing the
lighthouse from a God in a way or did he
you don't know yeah and like I said it's
very it gets more and more like
surrealistic as it goes on one thing
that surprised me about it was that it's
actually much funnier than I was
expecting you know like that was because
the tension was so high in certain areas
it only took a couple little funny
things a couple small things for the
audience to lose it because the audience
did laugh at a couple yeah sighs because
it was funny yeah but they were also
under a lot of tension yeah I can feel
them back there's a lot it was real
quiet for a long time it was very quiet
irrigator it is a creepy movie it's very
and you're not really sure exactly
what's happening so any moment of levity
they were kind they took advantage of
that and started laughing at it to try
to release some of their stress I'm not
fooled by these parlor tricks I'm
hardcore on new time no those games I
was in when the movie ended I was a
little bit pissed because I thought that
they could have shown us a little bit
more about the lighthouse and giving us
a concrete answer as to what exactly was
going on but the movie doesn't do that
you just got well like I said it's open
to interpretation like I said there's a
lot of myths want every time an
interpretation I almost want to
use the word purgatory yeah that's not
spoiling it too much but it you know
like I said it could be interpreted in a
lot of different ways it's just like
people are kind of tripping out on the
ways to how you can interpret the Joker
all right
The Joker ain't [ __ ] compared to this
yeah this is a lot more extreme all
right yeah it's a couple steps back from
Eraserhead
yeah not quite a surreal an authorised
career but but getting there almost I
would say it but a little bit more
surreal than Brazil though the move man
that's a good move yes we're than Brazil
yeah it's a good movie if you understand
this kind of if you're dumb you're not
gonna like this guy you're not gonna
like this movie well yeah it's
definitely not like a big blockbuster I
think I would assume that anyone who
liked the witch now the witch was not
funny in the least but you know it was
very serious and very creepy this one is
like that sort of but it has a little
bit more of like a black comedy kind of
undertone like slightly and I'm not sure
it's a psychological horror for sure
it's an art or horror yes it definitely
is and like I said I think that if
people are you know if you're familiar
with a 24 studios if you're familiar
with Robert Eggers who directed this
then I don't think that you will be put
off by this in any way I don't want to
say I might have liked this a little bit
better than the witch but it's kind of
hard to say because they were pretty
different like in their approach so I
don't know if I can really say that but
like you said it did have like almost
like a David Lynch II and yeah well like
an Englishman typing I'll do it I'm
gonna I must say it's a masterpiece that
doesn't necessarily mean I liked it
though I liked it yeah but it did piss
me off and I think that might have been
the intent yeah okay yeah it's a
provocative as opposed to do that so
it's meant to engender discussion yeah
and it's also meant to make you
uncomfortable and it was meant to make
you question things about the movie yes
way it could have gone because I meant
ain't meant to have a bunch of ambiguous
interpret
different interpretations on ambiguous
[ __ ] that they showed you that it might
be this or it might not be and it could
be this or it could be that I mean one
of the creepiest things to me one I have
to say to that both acting performances
were phenomenal yeah especially Willem
Dafoe was [ __ ] great and then was the
guy Poseidon was the god Poseidon
ordered the dude was just so crazy he
saw him as beside right it's that's what
I'm talking about ambiguous and you
won't understand I'm talking about TC
until you see it yeah you definitely
should sit I mean this is definitely bro
I was really got into it was the fire in
the lighthouse a Promethean fire the
fire prometheus stolen from the gods or
is it just the fact that they were
drinking damn [ __ ] oil right because
they had run out of everything else
lighthouse lamp oil because they ran out
of you know they couldn't drink the
water and then they ran out of alcohol
so we started to drink in oil and that
would make you see some crazy [ __ ] -
exactly like I said it could be either
getting right um it's all kind of
blended into one and experienced one
descent into insanity it gave me a
little bit of a shining vibe just
because of the isolation and the fact
that yours yeah and the sound effects
and the fact that you're kind of like
closed in and David these two guys were
closed in each other they didn't really
like each other all that much they had
to sleep in the same room then like he
and puffin the same reinter pissing in
the damn pots in front of each other you
know they had no pry bar from one it's
just like you know well under there
who's like a flatulent spying on each
other jerking off and [ __ ] [ __ ] then
reporting each other for jerking off we
know to me the scariest part of the
movie I mean I loved like all the weird
like surreal imagery like the mermaid
and everything like that but the
scariest thing to me was when there
started to be like some doubt about how
long they had been there or like what
exactly happened like was he chasing him
with an axe or was it the other way
around is that like really freaked me
out because I was just like well [ __ ]
now yeah who is crazy are they both
crazy well they were drinking that damn
lamp oil yeah this like I said neither
of them are reliable narrators
so you really don't know like what
really happened and what really what
didn't so it's a frustrating movie if
you it's a frost if you want solid
answers to things yeah but if you like
ambiguity like these kind of like art
flicks I got super into it I'm not she's
into it and I just like I I enjoyed it
very much weird words he was doing but I
thought was gonna clarify at the end and
in a reveal but it did I mean I have to
say though that I love that people like
Robert Eggers and Ari aster stuff like
that are making movies nowadays because
I love this like art house horror type
of thing like especially after all the
stupid like I'm not like I like the
conjuring and all that kind of stuff but
that you know there's so many of those
and they're really not doing anything
interesting yeah I kind of like it more
experimental this movie's gonna bomb
that's gonna bomb it's a great movie
well like I said it's great just did
really well actually
okay well that's a guy the first
director I mean Wilson I think horror
fans maybe I maybe I'm under estimating
people well horror fans in general a lot
of them kind of are into this I was
tight from what I saw on the theater it
was going way over their heads me it was
theater was almost full was almost full
but was going over their head as they
were leaving I could I could hear him
talking and they're like what the [ __ ]
was that that was weird you know do now
the people bought that were behind us I
had heard them talking about the witch
beforehand so they were like I said
anybody that saw this guy's first movie
would not have been like what the [ __ ]
was that you know because it's even
though the movies are totally different
you would have known what you were
getting into is movie yeah there was
some really cool like imagery in this
and it was just like creepiest the
actors were great I'm I have to say good
for Robert Pattinson who got famous
obviously for those horrible Twilight
movies good for him for doing like
[ __ ] weird-ass movies acting was
great in it yeah cuz he was in this it
was doing archaic archaic [ __ ]
accents
we had a faux [ __ ] knocked it out of
the [ __ ] park
he just leaned right into makin a king
of the [ __ ] see I kind of had an old
kind of an archaic New York kind of
sound in acts ya basta basta
I call them [ __ ] I say ye or parody
you know just Thank You Captain Ahab
yeah yeah that was like funny moments in
it like that yeah but the interactions
between them yeah but then it would kind
of throw you out of it you're like yeah
is he a parody is he pretending to be
that's what I'm like that you know like
a whole [ __ ] sailor stories you know
see you so yes there was some that they
had and he may have been a fraud yeah
that's why I was thinking on what this
well neither of them are reliable right
because like like you said like at the
beginning he said something about how
like he lost his leg or how his leg got
[ __ ] up and then later he said
something else and he goes that he said
and then he's and then that was like oh
I thought you said you had gangrene or
whatever and he's like I didn't say that
you must be mistaken so it's like what
like a big key the story is when you
started running and totally out of water
and all they did was just drink [ __ ]
rum yeah and then when I ran out of that
provisions yeah and they ran out of that
and like and they started drinking a
lamp
that's what [ __ ] really got heavy so I'm
sure that lamp oil I had a lot to do it
but yeah it's this is really like like I
said this is a film experience not for
your people that are just into like
regular hearted watch it's really not
but like I said if you enjoy watching it
remind you know what else that reminded
me of repulsion it reminded me of
repulsion the Roman :
Polanski movie so it's like it's not fun
but it's like really it's a very
compelling like experience because you
you feel like there's me is an
uncomfortable experience yeah you feel
like you're getting like sucked into
madness along these along with these two
people yeah but I like that that's what
what we're supposed to do is supposed to
make you uncomfortable if it doesn't
make you uncomfortable I don't think
it's very good but yeah so definitely if
you know you're into this thing you
should go check this [ __ ] out because
this wasn't like I said it's a batshit
crazy
and I thought it was fantastic and Burt
said the acting was good cinematography
was good everything it was just crazy as
[ __ ] it's a masterpiece I loved it it's
a magic
[Music]